TONIGHT WE ARE GETTING POWERFUL
NEW REACTION TO THE BOMBING AT
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN SOUTHERN
UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY CLAIMING A
WHILE AGO THAT THE ATTACK IS
PROOF HIS WORD, PROOF THAT
GENOCIDE IS HAPPENING IN
UKRAINE.
HE'S DOUBLING DOWN ON HIS
ACCUSATION THAT RUSSIA IS
COMMITTING WAR CRIMES.
CNN'S SAM KILEY IS IN THE
REGION FOR US.
THIS BOMBING IS CERTAINLY
STANDING OUT AS ESPECIALLY
RUTHLESS.
>> Reporter: YES, WOLF, A NEW
LOAD BUT NOT UNPREDICTABLE LOAD
AS WE LOOK AT THE DISREGARD FOR
CIVILIAN LIFE THAT THE RUSSIANS
HAVE SHOWN AND THE RECORD OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S PARTICULARLY IN
SYRIA WHERE THERE WAS TARGETING
OF HOSPITALS BY RUSSIAN AIRCRAFT
THROUGHOUT HIS SUPPORT THERE OF
PRESIDENT ASSAD.
BY HIS STANDARDS, IT IS A NEW
LOW.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKED LIKE.
>> WE ARE REALLY STRETCHED.
WHATEVER CARS YOU HAVE SEND THEM
HERE.
MATERNITY HOSPITAL, THIS WAS
RUSSIA'S RESPONSE TO A
CEASE-FIRE TO EVACUATE A CITY OF
A MILLION PEOPLE.
A BOMB DROPPED NEXT TO A
MATERNITY HOSPITAL IN MARIUPOL.
IT IS HOSPITAL NUMBER 3.
INSIDE A FRANTIC SEARCH FOR
SURVIVORS, EARLY REPORTS SAY
THERE WERE MORE THAN A DOZEN
INJURED.
A MIRACULOUS OUTCOME TO AN
ATTEMPT TO A MASS KILLING AT A
PLACE WHERE LIFE SHOULD BEGIN.
UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT RENEWED HIS
PLEA FOR NATO AFTER THE HOSPITAL
AIR STRIKE.
>> AFTER THE OCCUPIERS DO WITH
MARIUPOL IS ALREADY BEYOND
ATROCITY.
EUROPEANS, UKRAINIANS, CITIZENS
OF MARIUPOL TODAY, WE MUST BE
UNITED AND CONDEMNING THIS WAR
CRIME OF RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: EVACUATIONS FROM
OTHER TOWNS HAVE BEEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL BUT STILL LIMITED.
AROUND 700 PEOPLE MOSTLY WOMEN
AND CHILDREN WERE BUSSED OUT OF
EUROPE'S BIGGEST NUCLEAR REACTOR
WHICH WAS KEPT BY RUSSIA.
>> THE SHOPS ARE EMPTY, THERE IS
NOTHING THERE AND NOT ENOUGH
MEDICAL SUPPLIES, WE ARE TIRED
AND WE NEED TO EAT AND REST.
>> Reporter: IT MAY SEEM
EXTRAORDINARY BUT THESE ARE THE
LUCKY ONES.
THEY ESCAPED FROM A SHADOW OF A
NUCLEAR POWER STATION AND
RUSSIAN TROOPS.
IN COMPARISON OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE
ENDURING IN MARIUPOL, THIS IS
GOOD FORTUNE.
CAROLYN VOLUNTEERS IN REFUGEE
CENTER IS SET UP TO RECEIVE
PEOPLE FLEEING MARIUPOL.
IT IS EMPTY.
SHE'S BEEN WAITING FOR WEEKS FOR
NEWS OF HER HUSBAND AND
DAUGHTER, THIS MORNING SHE GOT A
BRIEF CALL.
>> Reporter: HOW IS YOUR
DAUGHTER DOING?
>> MY DAUGHTER TOLD ME SHE LOVES
ME.
>> Reporter: OF COURSE SHE DOES.
>> SHE'S ALIVE.
IT IS A MIRACLE.
NO FOOD AND WATER AND
ELECTRICITY.
>> Reporter: FAMILIES LIVING IN
A BOMB SHELTER WITH HUNDREDS OF
OTHERS, THEY CAN ONLY SURVIVE
ANOTHER FEW DAYS THEN THEY'LL
HAVE TO SURFACE.
PERHAPS TO FACE MORE OF THIS.
>> Reporter: NOW WOLF, THE TERM
GENOCIDE IS OVER USED.
IT IS A RHETORICAL PASSION THAT
THE UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT FEELS
BECAUSE HE FEELS SO ABANDONED BY
THE INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY OVER
WHAT HE SAYS IS THEIR FAILURE TO
IMPOSE A NO-FLY ZONE PREVENT
ATROCIIES BEING COMMITTED.
NATO FEARS AND CLEARLY STATED IF
THEY GET INVOLVED THAT COULD
LEAD INTO SOMETHING FAR MORE
CATASTROPHIC.
WOLF.
>> SAM KILEY AT THE SCENE FOR
US, THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT,
STAY SAFE OVER THERE.
PLEASE.
>>> LET'S GO TO THE UKRAINIAN
CAPITOL OF KYIV WHERE AIR RAID
SIRENS SOUNDED A SHORT WHILE
AGO.
OUR CORRESPONDENT CLARISSA WAR
IS THERE FOR US.
YOU HAVE BEEN REPORTING ON THE
DEVASTATING TOLL FAING
UKRAINIANS.
IS THERE ANY DOUBT THAT PUTIN IS
TARGETING CIVILIANS?
>> Reporter: WELL, WOLF, I THINK
IT IS DIFFICULT TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN ACTIVELY TARGETING
CIVILIANS AND HAVING A COMPLETE
DISREGARD FOR THE LIVES OF
CIVILIANS.
CERTAINLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME
OF THE PLACES THAT HAD BEEN HIT
IN THE BOMBARDMENT OVER THE LAST
WEEK PARTICULARLY, EVACUATION
ROUTES WHERE CIVILIANS TRYING TO
FLEE TO SAFETY, APARTMENT
BUILDINGS AND RESIDENTIAL
BUILDINGS WHERE PEOPLE WERE
LIVING WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND
WHAT'S INTERESTING AND VERY
TELLING AND CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT
ABOUT THIS MARIUPOL MATERNITY
HOSPITAL IS THAT SEVERAL HOURS
BEFORE THIS ATTACK TOOK PLACE,
THE RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER
SPOKESPERSON WARNED IN HER WORDS
UKRAINIAN FORCES WERE USING THE
HOSPITAL COMPLEX AS A LAUNCH PAD
FOR MILITARY ACTIVITY, SHE
CLAIMED AT THAT MOMENT THAT ALL
STAFF AND PATIENTS HAD BEEN
EVACUATED FROM THAT HOSPITAL IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THAT
MILITARY ACTIVITY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE IMAGES,
YOU CAN SEE CLEARLY THAT THERE
ARE STAFF MEMBERS THAT THERE ARE
PATIENTS AND CHILDREN AND THERE
ARE HEAVILY PREGNANT WOMEN,
WOMEN WHO HAVE JUST GIVEN BIRTH
WHO ARE BLOODY AND INJURED AND
HAVING THEIR WOUNDS ASSISTED.
IT APPEARS IN THIS CASE THAT THE
RUSSIANS UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS
WAS A HOSPITAL AND IT BECOMES
VERY DIFFICULT TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY ACTUALLY REALLY GENUINELY
THOUGHT THERE WERE NO PATIENTS
AND NO STAFF INSIDE THAT COMPLEX
BEING TREATED.
ULTIMATELY, AS THE MAYOR OF
MARIUPOL SAYS, THESE ARE CRIMES
THAT HAVE TO GO TO THE
INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL COURT TO
DECIDE.
AS SAM POINTED OUT IN HIS
REPORTING THAT WE HAVE SEEN THIS
BEFORE IN SYRIA PARTICULARLY
WHERE WE KNOW CONCRETELY THAT
RUSSIAN FORCES WERE ACTIVELY
TARGETING HOSPITALS, WOLF.
>> CLARISSA, MARIUPOL THE CITY
WHERE THIS ATTACK TOOK PLACE
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE UNDER A
CEASE-FIRE SO THAT CIVILIANS
COULD ACTUALLY ESCAPE.
ARE ANY OF THESE SO-CALLED
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDORS ACTUALLY
REALLY SAFE?
>> Reporter: REALLY SAFE IS A
DIFFICULT TERM TO CATEGORIZE
EXACTLY, WOLF.
I WOULD SAY HERE IN KYIV IN THE
SUBURBS WHICH HAVE BEEN SO HARD
HIT, ROUGHLY 3,000 PEOPLE
ACCORDING TO UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES AND LOCAL OFFICIALS
HERE IN KYIV WERE ABLE TO GET
OUT OF SOME OF THOSE HARDEST HIT
AREAS AND THE WORLD REPORTS THAT
THE BOMBARDMENT IN THOSE AREAS
WAS A LITTLE LESS THAN IT HAD
BEEN BEFORE.
WE HEARD THAT QUITE A FEW PEOPLE
WERE ABLE TO ESCAPE THE NORTHERN
CITY OF SUMY, THAT'S THE SITE OF
JUST SOME TRULY HORRIFIC
BOMBARDMENT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SORT OF
BROADER PICTURE AND YOU LOOK AT
MARIUPOL IN PARTICULAR WHERE FOR
THREE STRAIGHT DAYS NOW, THEY
HAVE TRIED DESPERATELY TO GET
THESE PEOPLE OUT AND GET
HUMANITARIAN AID IN, THE
SHELLING CONTINUES AND THE
BOMBING CONTINUES AND I DON'T
THINK ANYONE CAN CALL IT A TRU